un permis 470 kilomètres carrés que le
soleil va réchauffer nous sommes dans la
région des fjords qui ne sont autres que
des valets façonné par d'anciens
glaciers que les eaux marines ont envahi
en norvège d'un titude rend les contrées
intérieur du pays inhabitable or des
côtés de la région méridionale personne
ne peut vivre mais là il fait bon une
fable où le printemps et les étés sont
même très doux car si en hiver n'est pas
rare d'enregistrer -30 qui est mon
niveau que l'été il n'est pas rare non
plus de voir le thermomètre marqué plus
de 30 à peu près comme sur la côte
d'azur et ben il faut toujours vu avec
les moyens de son bord ici c'est le lait
de chèvre
il est précieux vous allez le voir on en
fait du fromage
voilà l'opération est seul et blanc par
je ne sais quel procédé il va devenir
noirâtre jugez vous même dans un instant
voilà vous voyez
précieusement mis en moule avec un
torchon ou mouillé enroulé autour de la
main il n'est pas rare du tout de
rencontrer en norvège des petites filles
qui se promène dans cette charmante
devenu la tradition veut là bas que l'on
porte très souvent les costumes
régionaux et l'on danse c'est très
agréable
ces princes c'est juste une façon d'être
un joyeux et guay est heureux et ça en
en vache n'est pas un violent non il
nous appelle ça une violent
l'homme est certes obligés d'accomplir
116 d'immenses efforts mais et les
norvégiens sarrance astucieusement pour
que les efforts inutiles soient toujours
évité il allait voir
eh oui in fine droit au but sans l'aide
de personne
avouez que c'est plus agréable que le
descendre jusqu'en bas de la pente de la
grange à un fjord ce paysage est à vous
qui vous aimez ce paysage alors je vous
laisse regarder
m
suivez la route accidentée au moins
aujourd'hui
une rencontre le moteur a peut-être un
peu chauffé
et les petits animaux curieux sont venus
voir pourquoi
pour ceux qui ont le vertige
et soudain il nous faut nous pencher sur
l'architecturé tout de bois c'est tennis
je pense qu'elle est construite de la
sorte de manière à supporter le poids de
la neige et en laisser glisser le plus
possible de son toit je ne vous la firme
repam cela me semble logique et les
églises typique c'est ce genre d'église
sont jalousement préservée dans les
campagnes elle orne le paysage et chacun
tient à ce qu'elle le fasse le plus
longtemps possible
on ne peut pas aller en norvège sans
parler bois les forêts magnifiquement
exploité fournissent des bois d'oeuvre
de chauffage et surtout de la pâte à
papier et de la cellulose et du papier
voici un départ pour l'otage
être flotteurs de bois et comme en
finlande une profession et c'est
dangereux
difficile la norvège est aussi le pays
de la joie de l'exercice physique de la
santé pas d'âge pour apprendre à skier
plus on est jeune plus c'est facile et
ce qu'il était indispensable de savoir
dans ce pays pour vivre simplement peut
devenir comme ici une compétition un
sport regarder l'homme en plein vol
est ce n'est vraiment pas laid
là bas on ne s'amuse pas à déblayer les
routes avec une pelle et un balai non ça
serait un peu ridicule et il n'est pas
rare que l'on soit obligé de creuser
d'imaginer d'inventer des routes de
cette sorte un peu partout l'eurasie
faire bien chaud bouchée du soleil nous
ne viendrons pas si près de la laponie
sans y faire un petit tour
et
le labo est admis nomades
il vit avec ses troupeaux il suit ses
troupeaux car le renne sait toujours
trouver sa nourriture mais vous ce
troupeau de rennes
eh bien il a senti que de l'autre côté
il existait du lichen que ce week-end
serait très bon à manger sans hésiter
ils se sont jetés à l'eau ils sont
suivis par cette barque qui tout de même
voudrait éviter un incident se produise
et
et la peau vivent de leurs troupeaux
et là bas on vit aussi qu de la pêche
une des ressources particulières et la
pêche à la morue on la fume on la salle
et cela permet de la conserver très
longtemps
non
oui le poisson ne manquent pas
c'est un charmant petit port bien abrité
vous souhaitez mieux connaître les
lapons c'est très simple nous allons
suivre cet homme il a par là un ami la
peau le cherche
si lui ne voit pas encore son ami lapon
l'a sûrement déjà vu
voilà il arrive et admirer sa
désinvolture
il va ans qui s'embêtent ans lorsqu'ils
sont courts et les skis courts qui sont
tellement en vogue sur nos champs de
neige à nous reviennent probablement de
là bas
les troupeaux sont la remarque et
l'épaisseur de leur fourrure
et très gentiment il va nous emmener en
promenade
promenade qui s'achèvera dans sa famille
c'est à dire dans la tente dans laquelle
ils sont habitués à vivre une tante
conique où il vivra assez entassés les
uns autour des autres mon dieu ça doit
tenir chaud
c'est le costume de printemps qu'ils ont
là le costume divers à une peau de bête
en plus
oui vous tout le monde rend par la porte
et à l'intérieur on fait du thé très
fort ça donne des forces
on est toujours très très bien
accueillis sous une tente la pole janka
centre hospitalier très développé
lui il cisèle quelque chose sur une
borne de rennes
et puis c'est le moment vous souhaitez
vous retirer de leur temps de rentrer
chez vous alors en hôte parfait
il propose de vous accompagner pour ce
faire il suffit d'un lasso et de la
danse
voilà celui qui va travailler et
prisonniers ont les attelles regarder
chez lui du bush est un batailleur il a
perdu un de ses bois
au revoir au revoir
et peut-être à bientôt
eh bien bon retour à eux et pour me la
semaine prochaine
ivan chagnaud vous a proposé voyage